-It is Tuesday,
it is time for "WeTweet."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ WeTweet, WeTweet ♪
-All right.
Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something that we should
post on Twitter.
I'm going to show you five
different tweets.
We're all gonna vote on whether
you like each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats.
I can see everyone just looking
at each other, confused.
But they should be there,
somewhere.
You can vote for all of them,
if you want.
You can vote for none of them,
Whatever you want, and we'd like
to see the results here live.
This is real.
Higgins, Roots,
you have clickers too?
-I'm a clicker.
-Yep, good.
Whatever tweet gets the most
likes, we will tweet it out
live, on the show, so you all
can like it and "WeTweet" it.
[ Audience ahs ]
Yeah, it's a shared experience.
All right,
you guys ready for this?
-Yeah!
-All right.
The first tweet is...
All right.
-Wow.
-Starting off slow.
I'm gonna say yes for that, just
'cause it's starting off slow.
But I -- I understand that one.
-Yeah.
-You wear the costume,
and then you ask --
You get it, and then --
-"Get it? Get what it is?"
-"Do you get it?"
-Yeah.
-I understood.
The votes are in.
They were in almost immediately,
I could tell.
[ Laughter ]
Let's see the results here.
Yeah, all right.
That's not bad.
All right, 122 said "no thanks."
All right, that's fine.
All right.
How about this next one?
The next one says...
[ Laughter ]
So, are...
Hm, I don't know about that one.
-Yeah, Rice Krispies?
-I don't know about that one.
I would have said,
"Snap, Crackle, and Pop
are a throuple, fight me."
[ Light laughter ]
-I'd say -- I'd say, "Snap,
Crackle, and Pop are a throuple.
Don't @ me."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, yeah. Right.
-[ Laughs ] All right.
I don't know about
that one either.
Let's see the results
on this one.
Oh, all right,
it's getting up there.
People are warming up.
-Yeah.
-To the idea --
-A little bit, they're going --
-They're warming up to the idea
and seeing that this is real,
in real time.
-Yeah. They're not used
to pressing buttons.
-These are big decisions.
-Yeah.
-'Cause one of these
could be tweeted --
-It's up to them. It's up to
you guys which one goes out.
-All right.
You ready for this next one?
-Snap, Crackle, Pop, man.
-All right, it says...
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, there you go.
You warmed 'em up.
-Yeah, warmed 'em up
a little bit.
I'm still not at -- not that
many people laughed.
-I think this one's going to be
the highest one.
-You think that one's getting --
the highest, do you think?
-The highest one so far.
-Yeah.
-Tariq, you think so?
All right, yeah.
I think it's up there.
What are you thinking?
Like, did we break
a hundred on this one?
-I think we might break --
Yeah, 101, I'm gonna say.
Or 98.
-What are you thinking?
-I'm gonna say 104.
-Quest?
[ Drumroll ]
-113.
-I'm gonna say 120.
-120, wow.
-Let's see the results.
-Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
-Wow, I didn't even know --
-It wasn't that good.
-That wasn't that good at all.
No, they're being very nice.
All right.
Next up, how about this one?
Here, it says...
[ Laughter ]
-There you go.
Come on, that's a biggie.
-Yeah, it's a lot to do.
-Come on.
-It's a lot to chew on,
but it's worth it.
-It's worth the ride, yeah.
♪♪
-You -- He got you on that one?
-I like that one.
-Yeah, I like that one too.
All right, I think
that one's up there too.
-I think it's up there.
But the last one was high.
-That was maybe
artificially high.
-Yeah.
Let's see the results
on this one.
-Oh!
-All right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Good, good,
but still not "per se."
-Not as high, yeah.
-"Per se" is the one, yeah.
We have one last one here.
This last one is...
[ Laughter ]
There you go.
-Come on.
You've got to beat 188.
-I think this is gonna --
-Come on.
That's the winner, people.
Come on.
-People are still laughing.
So, this one feels good.
-Yeah, come on.
Click yes.
-Go ahead, give a wave.
You're allowed to wave.
Go for it, yeah.
Can we get some shots
of the audience?
Yeah, give a good wave.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I think this one --
-I think --
-This one might be
the closest to 100%.
-I would hope so.
-Audience enjoyed this one.
I think so.
Let's see the results.
Yeah!
[ Bell dings ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow!
That's a history-making tweet,
right there.
History!
Thank you!
The winner is number five.
I'm gonna post this
during the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like, give it
a "WeTweet," and enjoy.